écoles fermées arrêté interdisant tout
rassemblement collectif jusqu'au 14 mars
dans le morbihan la préfecture a décidé
de prendre des mesures
cinq mille sept cents élèves seront
ainsi privés de cours
parmi les communes les plus touchées
celles de 'krach avec pour ses 3400
habitants l'impression de vivre en état
de guerre surprise de voir que même la
mairie est fermée et puis que c'est si
dr d'encre à quoi j'ai l'impression de
tourner état de guerre je comprends pas
de trop mais bon pour pas en faire une
psychose quand même à ce point là quoi
quand même on fait du stop parce que ça
va générer de la panique
effectivement déjà on voit qu'il ya des
régions qui sont vides donc
effectivement il ya une cantine une
panique qui s'installe
les gens font des courses et puis bah si
on est les derniers 1 on risque de tuer
être servi à paris le salon du tourisme
est annulé cent mille personnes étaient
attendues du 12 au 15 mars prochain tout
comme le salon du livre qui devait se
dérouler du 20 au 23 mars le musée du
louvre lui est resté fermé après le vote
d'un nouveau droit de retrait par le
personnel
de quoi décevoir les touristes est-ce
que je pense que c'est une bonne raison
non vraiment pas elle préférait être à
l'intérieur
nous avons fait un long voyage pour
venir ici je ne suis pas sûr que la
fermeture du musée arrête la propagation
les transports en commun ne sont pour
l'instant pas impactés des restrictions
sont envisagées en cas de passage au
stade 3 de l'épidémie le seuil d'alerté
maximum
mais aucun arrêt du trafic vous avez
compris que ces plans de continuité
d'activité
il vise à trouver le meilleur équilibre
entre le fait de constater qu'on a un
virus qui peut circuler
à ce stade trois plus largement dans la
population qu'il faut évidemment
ralentir la progression de ce virus et
en même temps il s'agit pas d'arrêter le
pays
il faut que chaque français devienne un
acteur de ce combat contre le
coronavirus a appelé de son côté edouard
philippe lors d'une visite
d'un centre hospitalier de bordeaux pour
le premier ministre se laver les mains
toutes les heures et d'ailleurs
probablement la meilleure façon de le
faire